another segment here this story I love
this subject alexis is spying on you and
right now we have one and it keeps
turning on whenever I say it's stupid
name but here's what people don't
realize your devices like your smart
your smart phone Google whatever Alexa
Apple are always listening all the ways
on now they'll try and low you into a
false sense of security and saying no no
no we're not recording you're spying on
you at all it's not true they're lying
they are took us out Alexa is listening
to you former Amazon executive reveals
he switches off his smart speaker
whenever he wants a private moment now
now why is it that a former Amazon
executive would be like I better turn
this off what do they know that we don't
well then what is it what is he talking
about - once he would you know know well
why would I want Amazon know the things
I'm talking about what if I'm upstairs
in bed with a lady mm-hmm and I'm like
here take this here and put that there
what if her name was Alexa well that's
awful but you can actually change it to
computer and stuff oh let me ask you
this are you concerned at all about them
downloading and listening to what you're
saying I mean oh no why not
because I don't talk about anything
important so you don't know that
strangers can hear everything you say
all the time some some some dude right
now is sitting in an office 23-year old
dude and you're talking about how you
got bad gas forming that bean burrito
and he's sitting there laughing with his
buddies and he's like showing you don't
care okay no I'm exaggerating by the
well I know it I mean yeah I have an
issue with people listening to me but
it's like I have a smartphone I carried
around everywhere always listening does
that mean people are going through all
of my day literally every single day
everything you said the millions and
millions of people that have smartphones
there's one person going I all right
I've checked this guy's day off he's not
a terrorist next that's am I talking
about I don't know it's not the NSA this
is a private company that gets access to
everything you say all the time let me
let me explain the limit explain so what
people don't seem to realize is that the
early iterations of smart assistants
yeah required you to say it would be
like say their name three times right
okay so some phone
still do this when they don't have
access to the companies and the servers
in the data connection yeah where it'll
be alike say hello good sir
now say it again now say it again it's
recording you saying it so you can pick
up your phone and that's internal okay
that means the microphone is always on
but it's not going anywhere
the way Amazon and Apple and Google work
whenever you say something it sends the
audio file to a company whose computers
transcribe that sound into text okay and
sends the text back to the device so yes
literally everything you say so when you
get the Amazon device it doesn't ask you
to say its name three times because it's
always listening and then when you say
its name that's when it starts actually
recording but apparently as we know
there's all the ways someone listening
because the computer has to be able
transcribe its name get it well yeah
this how it's always been
it's a Robert Frederick a former manager
of Amazon Web Services told BBC Panorama
that he always turns it off during
personal and particularly sensitive
conversations last year Amazon was
forced to admit that some of the
conversations recorded by virtual
assistant Alexa were listened to and
transcribed by humans so they admitted
Amazon says human staff listened to less
than 1% I'm guessing as 1% there of
conversations to check for accuracy and
the information is made anonymous before
they see it anonymous air quotes yeah
the spokesperson questioned why panorama
chose to quote a former employee about
technology developed a decade after he
left the company so so it was a decade
later that this guy is now talking about
it yeah and they were probably
developing it when he was you know when
he was still there yeah but if you can
imagine that was 10 years ago
so now nowadays they probably have much
easier ways to like see and review this
information check this out this is a
story from a while back
November 14th 2018 oh wow judge orders
Amazon to turn over echo recordings in
double murder case so what there was a
murder and there was a is echo what that
thing is called but that goes a small
one oh so this is the big one so so
let me show this to let me see this was
in the room and the judge was like oh we
need to we need the recorded it it
recorded when it happened
Wow so I really doubt as it was going
down the victim went Alexa record help
no didn't happen it was recording so
here's the thing when you say the name
when you when you call her name out and
say you know play music by whatever yeah
you can log on to your Amazon account
and see everything you've ever said to
it whoa
yes and so there were some things in
there where I was like that's weird
I never said that no all right I did not
mean to activate her because IIIi did
this as a as a gag or have you logged in
and checked it out Oh totally and then
I'm like purge purge can you purge it
yes you can you can wipe it but here but
of course that like you can put your
hound I show you that that you raised
your side of things
so you could say you could say le GS u u
P okay say that what is it oh hell EGS
Oh Eugene s you put your le GS u P put
your le GS u P but what was it spell
what's what is le Jian my legs okay put
your legs up okay and it turns on legs
up because it sounds like Alexa Alexa
for a little while I was able to go back
and see everything that I had said that
I accidentally turned my phone on for
that was creepy and you can hopefully
turn that off on him and it records a
ton so there were things in there where
was like a few sentences of a
conversation I had and I'm like oh my
god or at least I think it was like that
it was like there were weird things in
there where I was like thinking they're
all over the place clearly wasn't
intended to actually have been a request
or a recording and they would ask
something like did it do it right and
I'm like that's creepy so I would do as
a gag I'll go to it and I would say
combinations of words that shouldn't
activate it but do so here's what
happens when you look at stories like
this where the judge says it recorded it
and there's a pair this isn't the first
one there's some other stories just like
this where the Alexa was recording these
people without them knowing and they've
tried to get the recordings turned over
there was one instance where apparently
Amazon sent someone's emails or messages
to a random
tact in there yeah yep yeah producer is
freaking out
holy cow yep whoa so it's this simple
how do you think it turns on the
microphone is always act it has to be
able to hear you yeah it has to so they
do mention it's around 1% of people that
actually listen right that's why I was
asking do you feel that we need to check
that it's still working correctly it's
like and yet the when the person who
wants to be nefarious and or and or sell
your information it's making me feel
like Amazon's almost the new Facebook
you know Facebook had it's all bad
well yeah that I'm definitely agree with
you there but it's like Facebook has all
of our digital information that we're
like typing and putting in but now
Amazon's putting all these like speakers
in our houses so that and they're
listening to us so now they're getting
even more information about us that he's
probably they're probably selling I'm
you know they this Jeff Bezos but do you
know that Facebook knows when you poop
seriously it knows you poop yeah well
how I don't have facebook on my phone
though ah you you have a facebook
profile okay you have whether you delete
it or not
mm-hmm let's say you never signed up her
Facebook okay you still the profile nope
okay so I know you mm-hmm I have your
phone number in my phone
mm-hmm Adam Craig ler and a phone number
right your wife mm-hmm Adam you know
actually you might say husband or you
know hubby or whatever right whatever
she puts in sure your mom has Adam phone
number right we are all on Facebook
we've signed in on our phones and now
Facebook has access to our contact list
okay their computer then sees Adam Adam
buddy Adam bro husband you know cousin
sister okay and now they they know he
and you've never for the profile but now
they know your entire family because
they've corroborated your phone number
with what everyone calls you and now
they know so so they start then
corroborating so if there's a bunch of
other information too like if they talk
about locations yeah then all of a
sudden like I was here with this person
I'm messing it right there's these
people and I'm in the picture it's like
oh so it was there here's what happens
Facebook will display an advertisement
mhm and then people go like wow that's
really weird I was just talking about it
yeah it's not because the
listening to you it's because they've
predicted you so well through their AI
they know exactly when to deliver the ad
so that's why they know when you put I
mean but people will talk about
something and like I don't remember what
else I was talking to you about pens and
I've never seen an ad for a pen like you
know a pen like who has been better not
I say it like 18 times but I opened up
Instagram and the first thing I see is
this ad for pens and it's like I've
never seen an ad for pens yep ever
before if Alexa is already always
listening then okay so what is yeah this
is it's worse than you and you realize
it sure sounds listen what the
algorithms just kind your location data
on your phone
mhm you give the apps access to these
things okay because they have when you
open you know you post an Instagram
it'll be like it knows your location
already yeah it'll be like are you here
so they know where you're at
well I turn that so but I don't think
it's the dangerous thing about
artificial intelligence is that we can't
even understand patterns the way they
can oh man that is scary too because
they're gonna see the patterns that
we're not going to be able to see
ourselves and they're gonna be like well
we have to go with this and save
humanity just like all these crazy
movies that take AI know what it's the
AI will act in ways that you don't
understand
yeah because not gonna you're never
gonna freak out because humans freaking
out would be bad for the AI like what
like a virus like no no like to stay
alive like humans not reproducing
anymore how would that be bad for AI if
it's bad for AI if humans no the AI is
trying to hurt them so humans will only
so any artificial intelligence hmm that
is that is trying to sustain itself will
only produce outcomes that would be
beneficial to it it has no reason to
create human alarm okay but I don't to
get into the too much of that the point
I'm making is yeah you may have posted a
picture of a cat on Instagram I have you
have you may have you may have scrolled
down for exactly thirteen point two
seconds you may have also traveled one
point six miles
hmm for some reason we don't know why
but the AI can see it these things
typically always result in someone
asking for a pen okay and then you said
oh I need a pen and then boom the ad
pops up not because it was listening
because it can predict your behavior
that's why I was saying Facebook knows
when you poop they do because they can
look at what's around you me they can
look at the time you woke up because
your phone's not moving then your phone
starts moving in a client find space and
then your phone goes out gets an you
know it's moving at a high speed
vibrate of speed they can predict if
you're going to work if you're going to
school which means they know when you
wake up they know the average time it
takes from when a person eats drinks or
sleeps or has to go to the bathroom and
based on your previous activities it's
super easy for them to predict
everything now I use the pooping example
because it's the most silly but they
know when you eat they know when you
sleep they know when you're going in a
sleep they can predict all of these
things right in English it kind of makes
sense because when you get up and you go
into the bathroom go to the bathroom you
set your phone down because you're
getting into the shower yes so you're
obviously in the bathroom you're getting
ready for the different move done stops
right it moved a little bit and it
stopped and then it moves a little bit
more because you're brushing your teeth
and you're checking the news or whatever
and then you go down and you do your
other things that is unsettling I wonder
if flip phones still it can you just go
get a flip phone yeah yeah no GPS or
just like a new key that's on in here's
the point about artificial intelligence
for one humans need to sustain the
infrastructure of the AI if the AI was
sentient and wanted to survive and
propagate we don't know what's
intentions and motives would be we don't
realize but it's not going to Kermit er
will never happen because there's no
reason for the AI to ever allow that to
happen so here's what happens you start
seeing things in your Facebook feed okay
that make you think having a family is a
bad idea all of a sudden now humans are
reproducing anymore and in twenty thirty
years there's twenty thirty percent less
humans so the AI doesn't need to go to
war with you it can convince humans to
do whatever it wants them to do yeah and
there it is that's true
so they talked about terminator
scenarios nah it's just not the case we
could be living under the boot of an AI
and not even know it like right now yep
and why is it that no one's having kids
anymore because we're at war with the a
on its winning probably not but whatever
it is it's going on with our cultural
development is resulting in this point
is yeah it's true the best thing for an
evil AI that wants to wipe out humanity
is to keep us happy as we flushed out
ourselves on the toilet yeah it's its
best bet is to make us about each other
not itself and look at where we are
right now
my gosh yeah where think you figured it
out well it doesn't matter if you're
happy that's really what's happening
that yeah anyway it depends you know
it's like do you want to fight for a
future but you know the problem is
people think they're fighting for a
future but they're just fighting for
their own personal gains or right the
future they believe in that not everyone
else believes in and I mean I don't
always like individual people that just
think they're their gods the scary thing
is that the entirety of society right
now is dominated by an AI it is so like
Facebook algorithms more algorithms so
for instance like the rise of the woke
outrage culture as a result of facebook
facebook said we want to incentivize
keywords yeah that good engagement so
also these companies like Huffington
Post BuzzFeed Vox emerged where they
started advice started making more and
more outrageous well content know the
more keywords you mix together the more
likely that post will be shown to people
because it's hitting different
communities know so if you take an
article about feminism and then put it
on you put on Facebook it'll hit anyone
who's interested in feminism okay but if
you put in intersect you know you know
feminism and fetch aiming now you're
getting both communities right this is
why intersectional feminism became the
predominant ideology intersectional
feminism combines all of the oppression
groups brings it all so what Vice ended
up writing was an article that said so
here's what you can do you can read
about trans women get a hundred thousand
views you can write about police
brutality hundred thousand views you can
write about you know black lives matter
hundred thousand views but what if you
write an article that says trans women
of color leading the black lives matter
charge against police brutality in one
headline three or thousand views right
so now all of a sudden these digital
companies started manipulating playing
to the algorithm to you know which is
it's not necessarily AI so they're using
their I they're they're working in
tandem with it basically so what ends up
happening is Facebook their goal with
their you know out machining algorithms
was to produce engaging content which
was manipulated by other humans to
create psychotic ideologies that are now
infecting you know political parties and
resulting in complete insanity so the a
the problem a
I will not be it going to war with us
yeah it's going to be us like all of a
sudden for some reason farmers only grow
soybeans and then all of a sudden people
are starving to death and we're like
uh-huh because the AI says soybeans
people like right or it's like hey you
know people we're like cigarettes and
then all crops just flip the cigarettes
because the AI the machine learning
algorithms promoted this and all of a
sudden nobody has food right and then
there's a panic and then everyone's
hungry so I you know I tell people when
it comes to this stuff with like Amazon
Facebook and within the weird things
that are happening in the day that
they're collecting the real danger is
that we've lost control of our own
cultural development and now you're
gonna have weird things happen that make
no sense like somebody could make a meme
about I don't know kale and then all of
a sudden the algorithms promote kale for
it to an absurd degree no one really
likes it but farmers then see the
popularity switched to producing kale
and then all son kales in supermarket
and people hate it but they pretend you
know they're like oh I don't know and
now it's there so it's really world of
changing with all this already happening
this is really interesting because we've
never had something that's complicated
to deal with before we don't know how
we're gonna respond we don't know how
it's gonna change us are we're seeing it
so results are happening now yeah I
think when you look at how politics has
become fractured in psychotic it's
because of these big tech platforms it's
because of the spying at the data
manipulation and collection all of these
things have come together to produce
these insane circumstances so yeah maybe
maybe that's it wipes out humanity entry
sectionalism makes so much sense with
the algorithm right it's like it's like
mashing keywords tags it really is like
tags all the right ones you put them
together and you get the most emotion
it's that simple and so I always ask
people if you have a legitimate news
organization with with dedicated
journalists who are nonpartisan yeah
unbiased and you put that next to
BuzzFeed who do you think is gonna get
all the traffic most people make a
headline saying you know orange man bad
and people click it you know and the
news organization will make something
saying Donald Trump signs executive
order today which one gets the attention
there's the bombastic sensationalist
content that keyword stuffs they reach
more people they make more money the
investors come in this is what I'm
talking about about AI destroying us the
investors then come in and say we're
gonna support it because it's working
and that's the point I'm making about
one day all of a sudden the only crop we
have a spinach because the investors
come in and say spinach is great they do
nothing else and then all of a sudden
there's no food for the animals and then
we're like panicking and then the
government intervenes and all of a
sudden of this weird command economy
it's it's yep these systems are not
particularly you know being built in our
best interests they don't know what our
best interest is yeah so the you know
the easiest way to explain it is YouTube
made an algorithm to promote what they
thought would turn out to be Game of
Thrones and instead they got people like
like me sitting in my basement
complaining about politics yeah that's
not what they wanted but that's what the
algorithm supported they didn't
understand that yeah that's true they
thought these parameters will give me
these things nope it's a path of least
resistance man it was a lightning bolt
you didn't understand it yeah thank you
check it out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we're live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and if you want to
catch the full recorded podcast which
doesn't appear in these clips make sure
you join by clicking the button down
below become a member and then go to the
community tab of this youtube channel
and you can see all of our full episodes
don't forget to like share and subscribe
if you want to get more clips like this
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all in the next show
you